I'm about to ask this 15 year old a
ridiculous question sleepy would you
rather have ten thousand dollars or
what's in this Mystery Box all right
guys there's a lot of pressure it's a
lot of pressure what would you do with
the ten thousand dollars if you picked
it I'm gonna treat my family to a very
nice and fancy it's ten thousand dollars
your family an entire Village
knowing Mr Visa could be a car or
something okay that's a good point it
could be a car okay whenever you're
ready you may make a decision I think
I'm gonna be ambitious today I'm gonna
choose the mystery box if your
decision's final lock it in okay here we
go ten thousand dollar decision
money is gone and you just want a brand
new car yeah
are you old enough to drive sleepy I
mean I'm gonna get driver lesson okay I
will give this to your mom POV I'm the
dad bruh sorry Dad for our next
challenge we invited Ludwig hello I just
flopped you in a random scale replica of
a random place on Earth you can guess
what country you're currently in without
moving I'll give five thousand dollars
to a random viewer of yours can I win
the money instead of them uh no sorry
take the box off his head uh okay oh
wait can I just say it just know that
you know certain statues are in multiple
places around the world you're trying to
trick me because that's the Statue of
Liberty which is usually in New York I'm
gonna go us of a United States of
America correct do you want to do double
or nothing give me another one give me
another one next country if you guess
this country I'll give a random one of
your viewers ten thousand dollars
Brazil what what gave it away oh my gosh
the statue they're making this too easy
do you want to do double or nothing
again Jimmy I will take you for all your
worth all right next country we'll click
on Ludwig's newest video I'm gonna go to
the comment section just Dylan official
said WTF Ludwig has a cleaned up room I
did just clean my room do you get this
right just Dylan official gets the 20
grand are we sure that I can't be the
fan because I do watch my own videos no
server get the box off
what the don't Google if you Google I
not only want to not give Dylan the
money but I'll kidnap Dylan and we'll
only give him back four money think
really carefully oh this is hard okay
there's a mountain range and Pen nut
yeah I'll I'll walk it in Indonesia it's
actually Tanzania oh that's such a hard
one sorry Dylan I tried next bit fuzzy R
star get your mobs mom mama all right
yeah my mom's here I have my mom with me
or Star mom and Fuzzy's mom in front of
both of you it's an obstacle course the
first mom to finish the obstacle course
gets an all-expensive paid trip to the
Bahamas
start the challenge
walk forward with w and press space
while holding w
oh no you go forward okay you have to
jump it's like driving but not really
yeah
all right now do that same thing and
jump when you get to the edge
yeah yeah no mod it's been one minute
and neither mom has left the Starlight
let's make it a little easier
literally
no you don't know
oh no come on Mom you guys please we
haven't traveled in ages that's not true
your mom keeps traveling to the
beginning of the obstacle course I must
have a record for that
keep going my keep going you're in the
lead two more jumps
oh oh yeah yeah no way yes yes okay
okay yeah yeah
oh it stars mom you are officially going
to the Bahamas
give me back my PC B you could choose
Carl Chris or Chandler whoever you pick
will be responsible for how much money
you win I'm sorry everyone else I choose
Chris yay Chris pull out the bow
big Chris has three attempts to shoot an
apple off your head the further back you
go the more money you make if he hits
the Apple but if he misses you get
nothing oh no I wouldn't have been
chosen if I knew somebody's life was in
my hands where you want to go for the
first one take over okay I'm gonna go 5
000. Chris
stand still don't move
oh that was horrible should you go to
where I shot or should I try to pull
down to you uh are you regretting your
decision I believe in Chris as long as
he didn't move Chris take your aim you
got this you got this Chris don't blame
me I'm doing it oh gosh
wait what it hit you in the knee move an
inch forward I have not moved I believe
in you right there all right that's it
wait Chris before you fire B are you
subscribed to Mr Beast gaming of course
my mom is too all right I'll make your
Apple a little bigger
my hand is steady I fired
[Music]
I just won five grand I didn't have to
do anything yeah next challenge Calamity
hello you're gonna be stacking Cheez-It
crackers I want you to left click okay
for every stack you successfully place
I'll give you one hundred dollars oh my
God and while you're doing that let me
tell you guys about the sponsor Cheez-It
and Pringles they're hosting the build
for better contest you can build a
playground in Minecraft take a photo of
your creation and they're gonna pick one
of them as inspiration for a real life
playground oh boy
so far Calamity You've Won 700 that is a
lot of cheeses Cheez-It Pringles are
also partner of Minecraft to give away
350 mine coins with every eligible
purchase they even have this limited
flavor of Pringles suspicious stew just
buy one of the products hold on to the
receipt and go to the website
kelloggminecraftpromo.com or click the
link in description to submit right now
you've won eleven hundred dollars so far
I've never considered having that much
money before all right now it's moving
pretty quick oh this is gonna be the
tough one I'm freaking out man oh my
gosh
Calamity you won nineteen hundred
dollars thank you thank you cheese and
crackers and Pringles for sponsoring
this video Mario
oops chest okay
you just won five hundred dollars let's
go follow me open this okay okay now you
want a thousand dollars every single
chest you open your money will double
but have the chests are filled with TNT
and if you open one of those chests you
lose everything it's a 50 50. Choose
Wisely Mario so follow me follow me yeah
yep click this one why do I have to
click this one well just because I see a
green border around it oh yeah fair
enough no
go pick another chest which one's
calling to me here I'm gonna go to one
of the ones that are really far off over
here okay okay all right this one right
here wait think about it back up back up
Mario I'll open it for you
you would have died Mario you would have
died hey look at me get your head in the
game okay all righty a lot of options
here Chris Pratt you know the voice
actor Mario I think in that movie he
says let's go so let's go with this one
yeah oh four thousand dollars Mario what
are you gonna buy with four grand
nothing because you're not stopping here
are you Mario no absolutely not choose
very carefully alrighty well I'm gonna
go with this one
oh
man all right I'm still gonna give you a
thousand dollars for showing up Love You
Mario next bit Ricky Dane are you two
friends in real life yes maybe not after
this I've given both of you ten thousand
dollars to prepare for a battle to the
death use that money to buy weapons and
armor but keep in mind you only walk
away with the money you don't spend if
you win Ricky what are you thinking
what's your strategy zero and zero dude
you gotta send it really if you just
bought the diamond sword he would too
hey kill you you actually make an
excellent point all right I'm going to
answer it I could beat Ricky with a bare
fist I'm sending it you are crazy I'm
ready server drop the doors
for some reason you both pick leather
but one of you got an iron sword oh you
have an iron sword yeah
he should have spent more money come
over here come get your slaps
nah this is fine this is fine this is
fine Dave you're actually doing pretty
good Dave's getting way more oh my gosh
not a chance
you all day run for your life
oh one health bar left Ricky you could
probably kill him with your fist all
right for the content baby
no no don't you dare don't you dare
don't you dare
Dan would you say you guys are still
friends oh yeah until the recording son
[Music]